what about y'all's first kiss bro let me
take me there man who who's your first
kiss hardy
oh man god i don't even know what she's
not gonna like that
she does she's gonna have to she's gonna
have to i think her name i think
it was her name was lee ellen i know
where it was
damn how old was she l
she was actually an elder she was my age
believe it or not
lee eldon i think it was lee ellen was
her name ellen i never
you know what's funny is like they
always called her leigh ellen and i
never
noticed that ellen is in her name like i
don't
know i don't know that sounds crazy but
i always just saw it as leigh ellen
now that i think about it like ellen is
a part of leigh ellen and ellen is
definitely an older
lady's name but no she was probably we
were probably like 13 or 14
and we were at my my family that's like
she got a late start online
yeah i mean what was you doing before
that bro just
looking around killing hard dude
is that a late start i feel like it's
pretty late i went to the church of
christ where we started at about seven
or eight
if you're morgan wong that's a late
start okay
yeah yeah that's my baby i gotta think
about what company i'm in right
babysitter huh
yeah i don't remember how old i was she
was probably like 12 i was probably like
seven what was her name you remember no
i don't remember that's kind of [ __ ]
up that's heartless yeah she was
she i was totally morgan not to remember
her name
i mean i don't know if i was making out
with her but i kissed her i'm sure i
slept
did you like did you put the moves on or
was it like a cute thing
i don't know dude i just remember i'm
sure i was drunk
i don't remember it i was seven that was
20 years ago
look on snapchat you'll find it man
tick tock morgan kissing his babysitter
wasn't working while i'm doing his
babysitter's kitchen
i need a babysitter now
what about you ernest man my first kiss
it probably was like kindergarten
you don't know do your hands up here
i was like kindergarten uh this girl
this girl i think virginia bane
burkhardt i believe is her name shout
out to genuine
banette dude i think her name rambles
out her full name no
i know this my mom tells this story
because she picked me up from school
that day
my little preschool ass jogging down the
steps mom's there
and she's she said how was your day at
school i said i'm gonna marry that girl
in the pink panties
so i don't know how i knew that but that
was
that was a true story my mom tells it
she said and i didn't marry
i didn't end up marrying that girl my
wife wearing white panties
yeah i don't i don't know that was a
that was a rough one dude we had this
girl in my neighborhood and she used to
wear v-neck t-shirts her dad's right
it was italian brother it was fully
italian and i remember
she drew breasts she we were children
bro
she drew tits on her uh chest with a
marker
and let me kind of feel on them a little
bit but yes dude how do you think you
wear them
ah i hope i was 11. were you old enough
to get a little
did you get a little blood flow
and look dude i remember she drew him
too small at first and then she drew
them bigger
her first breast augmentation was with a
shark
that's a true story man oh my god and
her brother used to make us come over
and play in a bathtub and he was kind of
more of a
you know i think he preferred the
company of men really and he had us come
over there and
we would play ship captain and we would
all be and they had a pretty decent
bathtub and we'd be in there he'd be on
the side yelling stuff at us like was
the marines or something but it was
it'd be illegal now i think yeah yeah
you know it's a different time
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown